>> Hello, I'm Abhisit Vejjajiva, the Prime
Minister of Thailand.
Here at Davos, we are addressing a number
of significant challenges we
are all facing.
Not just the economy but also the issues of
food security, climate
change, and other issues.
To me, what's really important is all these
issues cannot be solved by
government or even by government and business
alone.
We need the engagement of civil society, of
ordinary people.
We need everybody to be aware of the common
challenges that we face.
And I would very much like to invite you to
participate at whatever
forum, at whatever convenience that you may
have, so that we all work
together towards a better world which gives
peace and prosperity for
all of us.
Thank you.